next time you stop at a gas station
think of it as a 100 a month tax cut or
maybe a 100 a month raise
that is a verbatim suggestion from cnn
which goes on to report quote a one
dollar decrease in gas prices equals
about 125 billion dollars a year in
savings for u.s households or more than
10 billion dollars a month that's equal
to about a half of a percentage point on
the nation's gross domestic product the
broadest measure of economic activity
and that's just a direct benefit lower
diesel prices bring down the cost of
transportation for all goods including
food if you add in the indirect benefits
it's real money
real money
in our pockets all because the price of
gas has gone down on joe biden's watch
thanks joe
except of course
that it hasn't
it just hasn't it's just not true the
price of gas has increased substantially
on joe biden's watch it's up almost 65
percent since the day he took office and
that's with him draining the national
strategic petroleum reserve through the
midterm elections after that it's going
to go right back up again
this article from cnn
this very article by what's his name
chris isadore
this would make a north korean news
anchor blush
pravda at the height of the cold war
would think twice
about running this kind of ridiculous
propaganda comrade that is too much you
have gone too far comer and
and yet cnn has absolutely
no shame
in the old soviet union at least pravda
admitted that it was the communist party
paper in the u.s our allegedly intrepid
and independent press runs this kind of
nonsense on a daily basis the only
difference is that cnn
and the new york times and the
washington post and all the networks and
on and on the entire establishment media
apparatus
doesn't even have the decency of the
soviets to admit that they're party
organs whose only job it is to carry
water for politicians i'm michael
knowles the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment friday is from ksync74 who says
when someone tells you their
four-year-old is trans that is roughly
the equivalent to someone with a
vegetarian cat it's not difficult to
figure out who is making the decisions
so very true
we've got to protect ourselves from all
this craziness when you want to protect
your wealth i'd really recommend you
check out alto ira right now go to alto
ira.com
michael cryptocurrency may represent the
future of money it's one of the most
exciting investment opportunities to
come around for some time but what about
taxes wompwomp you know the the biden
administration's about to send 87 000
new irs agents some of whom carry guns
to make make sure that you get shaken
down by your ankles with alto crypto ira
you can avoid or defer the taxes when
trading crypto like bitcoin alto offers
alternative investment opportunities
such as private companies crypto funds
real estate venture capital and more
alto crypto ira in particular is a great
way to start investing you can get
involved with a tax advantage retirement
account no commissions no paperwork make
an account in just a few minutes invest
with as little as 10 bucks no set up
charges it's absolutely phenomenal open
an alto crypto ira with as little as 10
bucks right now go to alto ira.com
michael that's a-l-t-o-i-r-a-dot-com
michael start investing in
cryptocurrency today altoira dot com
slash michael
if you wrote a hollywood script you took
it to a big print a studio producer in
los angeles you said here's my script of
a completely
propagandistic
news media that all they ever do is
shill for the dominant regime and you
brought them this headline
in this context gas going through the
roof cost of everything going up 40-year
record high inflation and you brought
them the headline america just got a
hundred dollar a month raise
thank you biden for for these gas these
gas prices that you can see with your
own eyes you got to pay for them out of
your wallet they're really secretly
they're really low
because two plus two equals five you
would be laughed out of the room they
would say it's two on the nose
you've got to you've got to cut it out
americans can tell
okay the joke is not on us
they think the joke is on us they're in
the editorial room tihi let's convince
let's convince all those hoy poloi
idiots that actually the gas is cheaper
he will pull the wool over their eyes no
the joke's not on us they are the joke
cnn is the joke they're the punch line
okay americans
recognize this stuff they are sick of
the propaganda that is why we cheer when
cnn's ratings go down it's why we cheer
when one of the most
one of the least bearable i was going to
say most unbearable but i get one of the
least bearable most tedious figures on
cnn brian stelter
just got canned and it brought back this
cl this montage
that tells you everything you need to
know about our establishment press
this brand new research by gallup says
american trust in the mass media is at
its lowest point since 2016 and near a
record low overall jeff zucker has
announced his immediate resignation as
the president of cnn this comes amid an
investigation into what jeff zucker
calls a consensual relationship what
happened and where cnn goes from here
you were caught masturbating on camera
you since then have been on leave from
cnn do i have all that right um you got
it all right sad to say the biggest
media story this weekend it's the firing
of chris cuomo from this network cnn
late wednesday a lawyer contacted cnn
with a sexual misconduct complaint about
cuomo joining me now the man who accused
don lemon of sexual assault his accuser
claims lemon started rubbing himself but
the even bigger point i think is about
what the press is is it produced by
reporters or by repeaters repeaters are
the talk radio shouters they're on tv
and radio telling the same story every
day president trump president trump
president trump trump trump trump trump
trump trump trump's trump trump donald
trump donald trump telling the same
story every day same story every day so
what are are we the reporters or the
repeaters obviously the the people at
cnn are the repeaters they repeat
whatever the regime wants them to say
and occasionally
occasionally they have to face some
consequences from that because the
people can recognize that this is all
ridiculous they can see right through it
not just because they go to the gas pump
and they realize wait a second i'm not
saving money on gassy and then lied to
me i'm actually spending a lot more
money i guess that's not the only reason
i think the other reason that people
started to wake up to just how terrible
the establishment media is is because of
the internet because there was a period
where
people really did trust
the establishment press those three news
networks that you would get on tv they
would trust walter cronkite i don't know
why they did walter cronkite was a
radical leftist he was a member of the
world federalists he was he lost us the
vietnam war
the guy was
not balanced not moderate not centrist
at all he was far on the left and yet
people said oh i trust walter cronkite
and now people say whatever happened to
walter cronkite
even some of the other ones later on in
the 80s and the 90s tom brokaw i trusted
tom brokaw these days though i don't
know what changed is it that the news
anchors changed
no i think it's that technology changed
i think the biggest reason that people
no longer have any faith in the
establishment press
is not even not even that the the anchor
has changed all that much it's that
people can now go on the internet and
look it up when you hear something from
the establishment press instead of back
in the old days say before the mid 90s
when you'd hear it and maybe you'd say
huh that doesn't sound quite right but
anyway i have no idea of figuring out if
it's true or not so okay moving on with
my life
now after the internet you can say hold
on
wait gas is cheaper now under joe biden
oh no obviously it's not it's actually
65 more expensive okay and this is true
even for political issues that are less
obvious than the price of gas this is
why dr fauci has had a very tough time
over the past few years dr fauci has
been in office for 40 years now he's
outlasted what
seven u.s presidents i think he's on
number seven right now with joe biden
he's the highest paid federal employee
even though his record is one of
absolute failure deception out
intentional lies incompetence screw-ups
going all the way back to aids all the
way up through the 90s especially right
after the war on terror he blew a bunch
of money on anthrax didn't get a new
anthrax vaccine a ton of misadventures
in africa we haven't even gotten to
kovid yet any lies about where he was
the funding for kovid the type of
research that created kovid most likely
gain of function research he said we had
nothing to do with that we had nothing
to do with the wuhan institute we find
out he funded gain of function research
at the woohon institute that he was
wrong i mean i could go on all day about
dr fauci
how is it though
that only now he's getting called out
for this stuff
it's not because fauci changed it's not
even because the american people changed
i think it's just technology we can go
back there was a clip that was going
around this weekend of dr fauci from
some 20 years ago he was on the c-span
show washington journal i myself was on
that show just a couple of weeks ago
and fauci
in his guidance on a flu vaccine
contradicted his guidance on the covid
vaccine
she's had the flu for 14 days should she
get a flu shot well no if she got the
flu for 14 days she's as protected as
anybody can be because the best
vaccination is to get infected yourself
and
if
she really has the flu if she really has
the flu
she definitely doesn't need a flu
vaccine
if she really has the flu she should not
get it again no she doesn't need it
because the it's the best it's the most
potent vaccination is getting infected
yourself
i don't know how clear i can be here
you do not need a vaccination if you
have been infected
generally just generally speak you get
infected that's the best vaccination
until i want you to take my fouchy ouchy
shot and then never mind don't listen
don't listen to that man
wait are you talking about that man i'm
you dr fauci shut up you i don't want
you don't mislead these people i want
them to take my shot and so he he's
obviously contradicting himself on the
chief central guidance
of kovid
of the past two years which was i don't
care if you've been infected i don't
care you've been infected twice you have
to get the shot the shot will keep you
from getting infected the shot will keep
you from transmitting it turns out
neither of those things were true either
what changed technology now we can go
back and we see it and once you see it
you can't unsee it and it cracks that
entire veneer that entire facade of
credibility people know better but you
know who doesn't know better
college kids we really need to be able
to
uh to get some sleep i know our blood
pressure is all going crazy here you
know with all this
mania in our political system but when
you want to sleep you got to check out
helix sleep okay right now head on over
to helix sleep.com knowles because i
want to invite you into my boudoir
that's right i've had my helix mattress
for two years now and i
adore it helix has several different
mattress models to choose from they got
soft medium firm mattresses mattress is
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot mattress is great for spinal
alignment to prevent morning aches and
pains even a helix plus mattress for
plus sized sleepers they've got a sleep
quiz that matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you why would you sleep on
a mattress made for someone else that
doesn't make any sense sit down with
your wife or your hubby go to helix
sleep.com knowles take their two-minute
sleep quiz find the perfect mattress for
you and your spouse they got a 10-year
warranty you can try it out for 100
nights risk free they will even pick it
up for you if you don't love it
you will love it they've got over 12 000
five-star reviews their financing
options and flexible payment plans make
it so that a great night's sleep is
never far away for a limited time helix
is offering up to 350 bucks off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners this is their best offer
yet so hurry on over to helixsleep.com
knowles
americans might know better college
students do not know better there's a
new poll out
this is from nbc news generation labs
surveyed a thousand more than a thousand
sophomore college students
survey revealed
almost two-thirds of college democrats
would not room with a trump supporter
62 percent so they probably would not or
definitely would not room with someone
who supported trump in 2020.
what's the number for republicans less
than half of that
only 28 percent of college republicans
say they would refuse to rub with a dem
someone who voted for biden in 2020.
what's the reasoning here well here's
what the dem said they interviewed some
of the people who participated in the
survey democrat kid says quote i could
never live with someone who supported a
racist homophobic xenophobic and sexist
person i could possibly room with
somebody who is a republican but when it
comes down to it donald trump is not the
average republican candidate so this kid
is saying that same thing that all of
the
extremely closed-minded liberals who
want to seem open-minded because that's
one of the values that they pretend to
appreciate
what they say is look
i i'm open-minded i could be friends
with a republican just not a republican
who ever supports any winning candidate
but if you support
i don't know liz cheney or something
then okay then maybe
maybe if you're a liz cheney mitt romney
republican i'll still probably hate your
guts but
maybe i'll talk to you so they interview
the republican kid republican kid says
hold on i'm going to do my my sort of
nice moderate wants to sound kind of
acceptable college republican uh a
person's political views do not affect
whether or not i would have a friendship
or relationship with them many of my
friends have vastly different political
views that i do but i do not let that
affect our friendship
and i don't mean to make fun of this
hypothetical kid
because
that's the nicer thing to say that's the
more reasonable thing to say
of course
you should if you get assigned you're
got a democrat in your
dorm or whatever
of course you you should be able to get
along we're all americans right well
actually on college campuses there are a
ton of foreigners but you imag we're
talking about people who voted in 2020
well i guess some foreigners probably
voted in 2020. but in any case let's say
for the sake of argument we're all
americans we should be able to get along
even people who voted for the other
party
on the surface this is crazy
on the surface here the republicans got
it right democrats got it wrong however
though it is crazy to refuse to to room
in college for a year or two with
someone who has different political
views
it is normal
to prefer to live with people who have a
similar general view of the world that
you do
that is normal
the lib here
is in a very crazy extreme
backwards way
actually articulating a pretty
reasonable concept which is
which is unity is our strength that's
really what they're saying even though
the libs love to say diversity is our
strength no one actually believes that
unity is our strength
doesn't mean you can't include people of
different backgrounds
doesn't it's not a racial thing it's not
a sexual thing it's not a whatever you
know it's not a i don't know geographic
thing
but you do want to have you want to have
more in common
with the people that you spend your time
with
then less
of course you do
that's that's what makes a community is
things in common
so yeah actually the democrat here in a
kind of bizarro way is espousing a more
normal point of view
you want to
you don't want just total uniformity but
you want to share
some basic premises with people and and
that can lead to much more fruitful
conversation
if you get a bunch of people in the room
who don't share any basic premises at
all let's say you get a bunch of people
in the room and they don't even speak
the same language are you gonna have a
fruitful conversation
no
if you get a bunch of people in the room
who agree on basic stuff what life is
kind of what what the purpose of society
is kind of
uh
really basic aspects of human nature
you are much more likely to have a
fruitful conversation and learn from one
another
the democrats get that the democrats who
preach that we need all sorts of
diversity and nothing in common and no
standards whatsoever
there they
in practice what they say is no you all
have to agree with us we need to have
some things held in common and
ironically that's a very conservative
point of view the conservatives used to
know that before the conservatives
bought the the bs from the dems hook
line and sicker sinker back in the 60s
when the democrats upended all the
standards and norms and traditions
there's actually something to learn here
the republicans have to be willing to
room with democrats because there are
only like seven republicans on any
college campus and the democrats have
the political advantage of being able to
ostracize and exclude people because
they are the vast majority 90 plus of
college campuses
but maybe we can learn something from
them maybe actually
we need to be a little more muscular
in setting standards and norms of
behavior and saying no we're not going
to allow your crazy bs to come in and
destroy our society speaking of
ostracism of conservatives on campus
there's a very nice piece published by
fire
the uh foundation for individual rights
in education
and it was on this this hubbub that
occurred with little old me little old
me whom everybody loves at the
university of saint thomas
uh some months ago apparently i had been
invited to the university of saint
thomas i actually didn't even really
know very much about this invitation and
then the school unbeknownst to me
refused to let me come speak
and the irony of it is that the
university of saint thomas is a catholic
school and they wouldn't let me come
speak because i hold catholic views on
the social issues
abortion transgenderism
sex all this kind of stuff because i
hold to catholic teaching they wouldn't
let me on campus because they wanted me
to hold to liberal teaching and so fire
the individual rights and education
group
as a headline university of st thomas
promises free speech yet practices
censorship by denying college
republicans request to host
michael knowles
first paragraph
the university of saint thomas
harmonizes free speech with its
religious mission laudably promising to
give its full blessing to students
expressive rights as part of its
catholic identity yet when the
university's college republicans chapter
sought to make good on the promise by
requesting to host political commentator
michael knowles st thomas rejected the
request because administrators didn't
like his views thereby betraying the
school's commitment to free speech by
violating the group's right to host
conservative speakers
in fires june 28 letter to st thomas we
explained how the university's viewpoint
based rejection of knowles violates
students expressive rights to host
sinful
satanic
or even blasphemous speakers so
i want to put a pause there i'm i am
actually grateful to fire for defending
me
and yelling at saint thomas for
rejecting me
but uh
respectfully
that's not what happened
the school's rejection of me
is coming to campus did not violate
students
rights to host sinful
satanic or blasphemous speakers thank
you very much
uh no gosh with a defense like this who
needs opponents
and i see what they're trying to say
fire is trying to say you have a right
to say anything you want on campus but
one no you don't and
that's a very extreme libertarian view
but it's it's not true you don't have a
right to say whatever you want on campus
but two
the content of my speech
is not sinful or satanic or blasphemous
it's the opposite actually
the school rejected me
because my speech was not sinful or
satanic or blasphemous the school
rejected me because my speech was the
opposite it was a christian speech
he was informed by
catholic principles and the catholic
school rejected me because the catholic
school has become sinful satanic and
blasphemous because they prefer
liberalism and leftism to
christianity
the conservatives have fallen into a big
big trap here okay
free speech absolutism i wrote a whole
book on this so i won't be labor the
point free speech absolutism is not a
conservative value
academic freedom is not a conservative
value
it never has been those were always
left-wing values the modern conservative
movement began with william f buckley jr
writing a book called god and man at
yale the superstitions of academic
freedom in that book he called academic
freedom a hoax
the catholic school has every right and
frankly obligation
to not allow certain ideas on campus to
tell teachers no you're not allowed to
teach
nonsense people go to a catholic school
to get a catholic education
all education has to have limits it has
to be somewhat coercive because you've
got to teach kids something
that's the point you go into college
theoretically ignorant and then you come
out and you're supposed to know certain
things and have a certain view of the
world and be educated which means
brought up now usually what happens is
the opposite kids go into college
knowing a lot of stuff and then they
leave more ignorant than they left and
this is actually even backed up by
certain social scientific surveys but
it's also backed up by common sense we
all know that that happens
so
no you can't teach everything you can't
have a school that teaches at the same
time two plus two equals four and two
plus two equals five
you can at the same time have a school
teach that good stuff is good and also
the good stuff is evil
you can't
you can't have those two things you've
got to pick you've got to have limits
here
so i appreciate the defense from fire i
really do i
i i tactically i'm really glad they're
defending me
but the reasoning that they're using
here
is not not correct now i want to talk
i want to talk about something i talk
about a lot on this show you know the
squishes i always talk about i'm talking
about the adam kinzinger's
the former the former congress ladies of
the world such as liz cheney
the the gelatinous uh rhino
invertebrates who disintegrate under the
very slightest pressure it's the kind of
behavior you would never dream of
engaging in or modeling for your son or
daughter and yet
the numbers are in
most of you squished this very morning
in fact some of you are squishing right
now whoa michael that's a slap in the
face hold up maybe maybe but it's not
for me if you are still
not shaving with the jeremy's razor and
you're still using one made by a company
that has called you toxic
you are the one shaming yourself okay
you're shaming yourself here and you are
funding the neo-marxist gender
ideologues who wish that you would just
disappear down and drain under your
unwanted stubble do not squish on your
values switch to jeremy's razors get
your founders series shave kit today go
to jeremysrazors.com jeremysrazors.com
the thesis of my book that came out a
year ago is that conservatives are wrong
about free speech we actually need to
put many more limits on free speech we
bought all the libs stupid arguments
about academic freedom and the total i'm
an absolute free speech defender
whatever and it was all lib stuff and
it's totally messed us up and we got to
get rid of it that was the thesis of my
book a year ago
and i'm not saying it was prophetic
okay i'm not saying that i told you so
i'm not saying it was an example of
nostradamus with his crystal ball but
this is becoming the issue right now
and you're seeing it especially down in
florida governor ron desantis passes
this great law to put those ideas into
practice in florida schools and say no
there's no such thing as academic
freedom here there's no such thing as
free speech absolutism you don't get to
teach critical race theory in our
schools you don't get to teach the weird
gender stuff to the little kids we're
gonna put limits okay and the squishes
are furious about this david french who
was a kind of conservative columnist
fairly prominent one always a little
more on the libertarian side now i think
he's pretty firmly a liberal or
left-wing
columnist i'm just a communist freudian
slip no he's clearly center-left at
least but he's attacking desantis for
this and he says the desantis attack on
the first amendment illustrates how the
word conservative lost meaning for
20-plus years conservatives attacked
campus speech codes upholding free
speech as a core value now desantis
passes his own speech codes and it's
conservative to support them
yes
yes it is you got it david you figured
it out and by the way i got to give
david credit here he even admits
that the idea of free speech absolutism
and academic freedom as a conservative
value is only about 20 years old that's
what he says he says for 20 plus years
conservatives were really against campus
speech codes and we're really against
these incursions
on standards and and uh
norms or rather the the creation of
these standards and norms
right what about more than 20 years ago
did conservatism just get invented 20
years ago no it's a much longer
tradition even post-war conservatism has
been around for 70 years and the
conservative tradition is many centuries
old and for virtually all of that time
conservatives have not been
the defenders of saying whatever you
want whenever you want to say it in any
context no way conservatives are the
defenders of chivalry and the truth and
virtue and education which necessarily
requires limits that's what it's about
david is admitting here that it was
these squishes or the hyper super duper
libertarians or whatever you want to
call them who are the ones who perverted
conservatism
and that's gone on for about 20 years
and it's been a complete disaster and
then you saw a reaction against that
from the actual conservatives you so you
saw reaction against that really the
trump candidacy is a reaction against
that kind of perversion of conservatism
and now
the the squishes who
who have been pushed to the side again
they've all left and now they've sided
with the libs
i'm glad we're returning to normal
nature is healing
nature is here that's what they said
during covet nature is healing
the
the conservatives are returning to
standards and norms
we we were the virus yeah desantis by
the way absolutely crushing it forget
about the education stuff forget about
the curriculum reform
ron desantis just announced the arrest
of 20 election fraudsters
going back to the 2020 election
governor ron desantis here we are the
press release right here
in 2020 florida ran an efficient
transparent election that avoided the
major problems we saw in other states at
the same time the election was not
perfect which is why we continue our
efforts to ensure the integrity of our
elections our new election crimes office
love that election crimes office
has sprung into action to hold
individuals accountable for voter fraud
today's actions send a clear signal to
those who are thinking about ballot
harvesting or fraudulently voting if you
commit an elections crime you will be
prosecuted to the fullest extent of the
law love that it's just so weird
that he would prosecute these 20 people
because i was told there was no election
fraud
the libs reliably told me
that there was no election fraud in
2020. so how are these 20 people
being prosecuted
by the election crimes division
in florida which was a state that really
didn't have a lot of election problems
certainly not like georgia not like
pennsylvania not like wisconsin where
there's all sorts of weird stuff
the election officials violated the
state constitution in the case of
pennsylvania and where people were not
allowed the election poll watchers were
not allowed to look at the count going
on and the counting just oddly stopped
in the middle of the night went on for
weeks then afterward and it's just a lot
of weird stuff
what's that about
what's so great here
is that
desantis is doing all the right things
politically on all those regular
political issues on education on
transing the kids on pro-life he could
maybe move a little further on pro-life
but he's moving in that direction on
woke corporations when he took on disney
on he's doing the right thing on all of
these political issues but election
fraud
that is a meta-political issue
that's the politics of politics
that's the rules about how our political
system actually works
because
let's say you get all the people on your
side on all of those regular political
issues
but you've got election fraud you don't
have integrity in your electoral system
well then all that popularity and a buck
50 will get you cup of coffee it doesn't
really matter in biden's economy you
need five dollars to get a cup of coffee
but the premise is the same the point is
the same
if you don't if you don't have a stable
political order where the rules are
clear and everything's fair and square
then it doesn't matter how many people
you went over to your side because the
cheaters are going to rig it all the
time so desantis is going in there and
this is really important too because
right now it looks like donald trump is
going to be the republican nominee in
2024 especially after the mar-a-lago
raid
and some trump supporters are
criticizing desantis for not coming out
strongly enough against it he tweeted
about it he said it was awful he said it
was banana republic stuff
but the trump supporters want one action
especially because trump and desantis
seem to be the leading candidates right
now in 2024.
so for desantis to make this
an important political issue for him
is a is a great appeal to a lot of trump
voters
because
and this gets back to liz cheney and
adam kinzinger and all this nonsense
your view of what happened in 2020
is a good indicator of what you believe
about pollux general politics generally
if you
insist that 2020 it was the most secure
election ever it was totally kosher
aboveboard there was no rigging there
was no fraud there was no nothing how
dare you deny the election if you say
all that stuff
you are either a lib or a squish you are
i don't know any serious conservative
who really says that
if you admit okay
yeah they changed all the rules you
don't need to go all the way to dominion
voting machines rigged it or you know
aliens from outer space or anything you
can if you just observe i think the
undeniable fact that the libs changed
all the rules beforehand
and got caught doing some shady stuff on
election day too or rather election
month because they extended it if you
if you admit that
i think you're probably a little bit
more on the conservative team here
because that obviously happened there
was fraud there was
rigging
of course there was
and desantis is saying that too we got
to get that in order why did the
republicans lose the georgia senate
races
remember there was on election day
those the two republicans kelly lefler
and david perdue they lose in in georgia
but then there's this kind of runoff
election go just a few weeks later and a
lot of republicans didn't show up
some people blame trump for that because
he was
contesting that he said it's useless
forget about the vote but he did then
encourage people to go out and vote
regardless
conservatives were depressed and
discouraged and they said i guess my
vote doesn't really matter because the
people conducting these elections are
ignoring a lot of the rules we're
changing the rules
so you've got is it is
priority number one really more than any
of the individual issues to say we need
to trust our election system and you
know how you have faith in your election
system you take the people who break the
rules on elections and you throw them in
the can
that's how you have faith in it
and frankly even more than these people
who commit an election for themselves
i want the ballot harvesters i want the
democrat operatives i want if they in
any way violated any law including
jaywalking i want the book thrown at
them
because they are frankly the bigger
problem even than the people that allow
this stuff
that allow themselves to be used for the
purposes of election fraud it's so
important because the issue
the issue when it comes to the the
election stuff is not what decision
should we make about this issue or that
issue the question becomes who makes
the decisions
americans know better
americans know a lot better than this
okay if you talk to the elites
really in both parties but especially in
the democrat party and you tune in to
all the establishment news you're going
to hear
illegal immigration is great nobody's
illegal it's not even illegal i mean
it's against the law but they're future
undocumented americans and they're our
strength and that we need more of that
diversity even though the blue city
mayors when texas ships all the illegal
aliens up to them they say no we don't
want this this is a strain on our
resources but send them to texas it's
our strength we want we need more of
that more we have two million a year
let's get three million or five million
a year
the majority of americans say otherwise
according to an npr ipsos poll
the majority of americans consider
illegal immigration to be an invasion
an invasion
in response to the statement that the
situation at the southern border
represents an invasion
the majority of respondents said yes
28 answer that that statement is
completely true
25
say that statement is somewhat true
there's one time i got into a real
debate with a conservative friend of
mine over the use of the word invasion
i said obviously what's going on at the
southern border is just it is an
invasion he said oh wow that's
outrageous that's hyperbolic that's not
that's not true you shouldn't say that
so what what's not true about it what's
an invasion an invasion is when
a large number of people
make an incursion into another group of
people's territory
that's what's happening
that you don't need to have a formal
uniformed army to invade something you
just go just a large group goes and goes
into someone else's territory that's an
invasion
i don't i don't know how else to
describe what's going on at the southern
border
and you will hear from the elites on nbc
and cbs and new york times or whatever
they're going to say
you can't use that language that's the
extreme fringe fascist
neo-nazi
racist all the stuff they call us that's
that's what they say no actually that's
what the majority of americans say
according to a poll from npr
a very left-wing outlet
everyone agrees paul after poll after
paul there was a poll now probably four
or five years ago from harvard harris
poll that came out
and it asked
what americans thought about the number
of immigrants who should be coming in
the majority of respondents said that we
should not only not increase the number
of immigrants who come in
but that we should drastically decrease
the number of immigrants not just the
illegal immigrants the legal immigrants
too because don't forget we've got two
million illegal immigrants crossing this
year probably actually a lot more than
that
we also have a million legal immigrants
who come in the vast majority of
respondents who were not told
what the immigration levels actually are
they were just asked what would you like
the level to be two hundred thousand
five hundred thousand a million two
million
vast majority wanted to drastically
reduce the number of immigrants so
everyone basically agrees on this why
does nothing get done
why does nothing get done because
there's a difference between what the
people want
and how they would govern themselves if
they were in control
and what the what the regime gets to do
and when we use that word regime i'm not
just talking about joe biden i'm not
just talking about the democrats i'm
talking about the way that political
power is actually exercised in america
which is different than what the
constitution says and it's different
from what you learn in schoolhouse rock
and it involves a lot of other interests
that you don't see laid out in your
civics class it involves the chamber of
commerce and it involves
the a weird collection of the media and
international institutions and the
financial sector and
a lot of people who represent different
trade interests and entrenched
bureaucrats and academia and all of that
together
majority of the american people want
something on such a basic issue as who
gets to come into the country
and yet it never gets done
it never gets done why is that
well because we need to pay more
attention to the meta-political issues
who has power how is that power
exercised speaking of invasions
there is a crazy story coming out of
russia that's not getting nearly enough
play
daria dugina
29 year old daughter of a very prominent
russian philosopher
she was assassinated over the weekend
she died after the suv that she was
driving
exploded 20 miles west of moscow
the suv was not her own the suv belonged
to her father alexander dugan who is a
philosopher
fairly well known and he's gotten a lot
of publicity in the west
and and p in the west they they refer to
him as the putin's brain
as the basically the secret puppet
master behind vladimir putin's regime i
don't know that that's a fair
description
actually if you look at alexander
dugan's role on the ground in russia i
don't i don't think that's really fair
at all he was pulled out of his
professorship at a university by the
political powers there's i don't think
there's any evidence he's even met
vladimir putin
that you don't see a real long
correspondence between the two men so it
may be the case that his role in the
putin regime is being exaggerated but
alexander dugan is very much in favor of
the invasion of ukraine alexander dugan
is very much in favor of a much more
muscular russian foreign policy
so there's no doubt about that that
there is some alignment although
apparently he and he and putin have had
differences of opinion as well
dugan's even criticized putin
either way
do we defend this kind of stuff we don't
know who killed
who was trying to kill dugan probably
and who ended up killing his daughter
it could have been
could have been ukraine or western
allies though ukraine is denying it
it could have been russians who were
anti-putin
could have been domestic russians who
are anti-putin i don't really know i'm
not and i don't have the expertise for
it and i'm not that's not even what i'm
most interested in
the thing that i'm most interested in is
the reaction from some of the
commentariat here in america
because ironically the people who most
seem to to
argue against these things in the
abstract the people who are most who
most likely to condem political attacks
on philosophers or commentators or
journalists
alexander dugan's daughter daria was a
political commentator of sorts herself
they're the ones most likely to embrace
it in practice
there's a woman who's written for the
washington post in the new york times
julia ioff
who was retweeting someone else who was
quoting a verse of the bible
and she tweeted out about this
he who sows the wind shall reap the
whirlwind hosea chapter 8 verse
7.
a photo of alexander dugan author of the
russian world ideology driving putin's
armies in ukraine at the scene of the
explosion that ripped up the car he was
supposed to be in and killed his
daughter and said
really dark stuff because you see the
guy he's looking his hands on his head
could you imagine regardless of what you
think about russia or ukraine or war or
no matter how awful you think this guy
is this man is witnessing
people blow up his daughter
almost certainly because they don't like
his politics and he's watching that
happen
and you have
liberal journalists
basically giggling about it
what happened to the sacred rite of free
speech what happened to the free
marketplace of ideas what happened to we
would know we should never attack
writers or commentators or philosophers
certainly
what happened to all of that well no but
we don't like this guy
this guy's really bad
he's the he's look what julia i off said
she goes
he his ideology is driving putin's
armies in ukraine what
i don't even know that that's true
but
this guy whatever you think of this guy
you might say he's got the worst
ideology in the whole wide world
but you
he's not the one launching the armies
into ukraine
you want to blow up putin go blow up
putin this guy's he's a writer
and yet you've got the very liberals who
defend that free marketplace of ideas
they're the ones as always as well
because we know in practice that the
libs don't believe any of that crap the
only people who believe that stuff
about the sacred free marketplace of
ideas where you have the right to say
whatever you want however blasphemous
however this however that
it's just the it's the conservatives who
got hoodwinked it's just the squishes
who believed the liberal propaganda in
the 1960s
and
and then
conceded everything and surrendered and
let the libs take over society
would you defend this i don't think so i
don't think people would defend
blowing up a writer's daughter i don't
think so
speaking of coercive liberalism this
story this is really spooky
this is a daily wire exclusive vanguard
is
i think it's the largest provider of
mutual funds in the world second largest
provider of etfs after blackrock
which also has gone just as woke as
vanguard vanguard just had a training
that they subjected their employees to
vanguard has seven trillion dollars of
assets under management when vanguard
says they want something the companies
under management generally do it
and vanguard had a diversity equity and
inclusion training
to get all of the white men associated
with vanguard and the companies that it
invests in
to get on board with the woke philosophy
this research that i'm about to present
to you
is actually an act of accidental
exclusion or active inclusion depending
on how you look at it in terms of us
really insurance and partnering with
some of the leading companies in the
field to ensure
that white men white male managers
are actively included in the dei
conversation
and that's the piece of research and
that's the critical level that we're
here to talk about today engaging white
male managers and advancing diversity
and inclusion
we partnered with as i mentioned some of
the four most thinkers in the dei field
and are so thrilled at vanguard for
being one of our leading sponsors i'm
gonna translate that from all that woke
gibberish that you just heard when she
says they need the white men in the
middle management they need to be
actively
included to get on board what that means
is that the companies need to force the
white guys into a re-education camp
presumably one being led by this woman
she says the white men need to be held
accountable there's clear expectations
set for dei prioritization
engagements and outcomes
there's clarity on how both senior
leaders and middle managers will and
should be held accountable
that we reinforce accountability through
performance management process and
feedback channels sort of added
commentary here i would say just like we
do for business results that are so
important right
we need accountability through the
feedback channels and just like we have
for their actual productivity we're
gonna do that for this woke ideology the
translation is fire the white guys if
they don't pledge fealty to this new
woke racial hierarchy that people like
this crazy lady are pushing and then
finally finally you have the insistence
by vanguard that white men
be held to uncomfortable
criticism
do be aware of implicit biases and work
to understand your blind spots this is
one of the ways that inclusion training
can help us all
no i'm sorry
do learn how to listen
and accept criticism with grace even if
it's uncomfortable
a growth mindset principle in many ways
is if you're growing it's likely
uncomfortable this isn't supposed to be
easy it's supposed to be hard this isn't
supposed to be easy it's supposed to be
hard especially to those white men the
the translation here is the white guys
are going to be held to a different
harsher standard and we're all supposed
to go along with this okay this is being
pushed not by the government even this
is being pushed by what we what we call
the regime the blob the establishment
the power structure it's being pushed by
a company with seven trillion dollars in
assets under management when they say
they want something like this they get
it from their companies this is what
conservatives have to push back against
and if all conservatives can offer is
what the same kind of platitudes they've
offered for the last 20 years which is
just get the government out of my life
just less government then we're not
going to do anything because the power
that's really being wielded in our
society is being wielded largely outside
of the government
by the propagandists in the media by the
insane ideologues in corporate america
by all by the lunatics in academia
that's where it's being wielded
some people get it that we've got to
fight them on those grounds that we've
got that's what desantis is doing with
the education bill in florida that you
see a tax on what corporate on what
corporations for that matter too that's
going to be the way of the future if we
do not lean into that we will not
conserve a damn thing
the rest of the show is continuing now
you don't want to miss it if you're not
a member
okay and the special member block where
we get rid of the hoi polloi it's just
us it's very exclusive with the creme de
la creme where we can speak a little bit
more freely than we can on certain
social media channels uh if you're not
going to join us there i don't know i
can't help you man you're not going to
make it click the link in the
description below join us we'll see you
over there
[Music]
[Music]
you